in this video we'll talk about
metabotropic receptors
metabotropic receptors are type of
receptors
which upon binding to ligand
lead to the production of certain
metabolites
that is why they are known as
metabotropic receptors
generally metabotropic receptors are g
protein coupled receptors and when it is
activated it can lead to activation of
several other intracellular components
and second messengers that might trigger
other intracellular events
in this video we will try to understand
the mode of action of metabotropic
receptors and where we can find them
one common place where we can find the
metabotropic receptor is our nervous
system
in the nervous system there are two
types of receptors which are found one
is ionotropic receptors another is
metabotropic receptors and in this video
we'll focus on the metabotropic
receptors and its mode of action
[Music]
before starting we should understand
that ionotropic receptors are important
for fast response whereas metabotropic
receptors are generally slow in terms of
responsibility
we would understand why that is
important in a moment
so let's try to understand what are the
ligands for metabotropic receptors
metabotropic receptors could have a
large variety of ligands
that is like small molecules
transmitters monoamines peptides
hormones and even gaseous molecule
we can try to understand the mechanism
of action by taking some live examples
we can see metabotropic receptors in our
nose in our olfactory system all the
olfactory receptors are actually
metabotropic receptors
and they are responsive to specific
gaseous molecule
and that helps us
in terms of smell
so olfactory receptors are metabotropic
receptors so here we are seeing a
portion of the olfactory epithelium
here you can see
there are
ligands maybe a gaseous ligand which can
bind to olfactory receptor marked here
in green
this ligand binding triggers a g protein
coupled receptor response so the alpha
subunit of g protein gets dissociated
and it activates adenylate cycles
adenylate cycles in turns generate
cyclic amp from atp and this
this cyclic amp leads to activation of
cyclic nucleotide gated channels which
leads to
influx of cations inside these cells
this actually depolarizes the cell
and sends the signal to the brain
now also we can see these kind of
receptors
in other cases
so for example in glutamatergic system
we can definitely see isotropic
glutamate receptors but also we can see
metabotropic glutamate receptors present
in the post synapse
and it helps in the nerve conduction
so metabotropic glutamate receptors are
g-protein-coupled receptors and they
help in ionic influx but in an indirect
fashion they are not directly linked to
the channel or they are not
ion channel itself
so
the way they can help us they can help
trigger the response is the following we
take an example of hippocampal neurons
where we can find imbuer 5 which is one
kind of metabotropic glutamate receptors
upon glutamate binding it can activate
specific g protein
that ultimately activates several other
mediators such as homer and that
triggers nmda receptor activation nmda
receptor triggers iron flow inside the
neuron
and that is how
this response is taken care of and this
is important for synaptic plasticity in
hippocampal circles
now muscarinic acetylcholine receptors
are other examples of metabotropic
receptors
these are found in the cholinergic
system
and muscarinic acetylcholine receptors
are present throughout the central
nervous system in the synapse also
outside the nervous system in
neuromuscular junction and in peripheral
nervous system we can see muscarinic
acetylcholine receptors
so muscarinic muscarinic acetylcholine
receptors upon acetylcholine binding
triggers a gq mediated response which
can further activate phospholipase c
thereby activating second messengers
like ip3 and d80 which has their own
downstream effects
alternatively
the muscarinic acetylcholine receptor
can trigger gi or go type of
receptors or g proteins
so the gi protein inhibits the adenylate
cycles
and that leads to
depletion of
cyclic amp level that means that atp
cannot be generated to cyclic amp
this decrease in cyclic amp level is
also important and it actually
regulates the activity of
ion channels and thereby it modulates
neuronal activity we can also find
another example in the gabaergic system
so the gaba b-type receptor is actually
an example of metabotropic receptor
and it works by a gi
type of
g protein
so gaba binds to the gaba receptor b
that triggers
the g protein to dissociate into the
beta gamma segment and the g alpha
segment this beta gamma segment actually
activates guard channel which is a
potassium channel and it leads to the
outflux of potassium thereby decreasing
the neuronal activity or it has it's
having a prolonged inhibitor reaction
also the alpha subunit can actually
inhibit the adenylate cycles thereby
decreasing the cyclic amp level
this in turns
kind of uh inhibit the calcium influx
via several calcium channels
it has other models so cyclic
amp-dependent modulators of
voltage-gated
channels can be
modulated using this kind of signaling
system and thereby calcium implants is
decreased
so moral of the story
greater number of positive ions are
moving out of the cell and lesser number
of ions are coming inside of the cell
this leads to an inhibitory effect
of the gaba b type presenter
so in this video we discussed quite a
lot of examples of metabotropic
receptors how they work each of these
cases we have seen that they work in a
different fashion but there is a
commonality between all of these actions
all of these receptors use kind of
intracellular responders second
messengers to
orchestrate their function and that is
the essence of metabotropic receptors
you can go get many nodes and flashcards
in my facebook page and instagram you
can follow us using this kind of this uh
handle animated biology with perfect all
the link is provided in the description
don't forget to check it out you can
support our channel via super like
option which is present in the right
side corner of the video
by clicking on that you can support our
channel your small support it's a lot
for us alternatively you can use patreon
or you can use this
qr code for support for supporting our
channel
if you wish to connect all the social
media handles are provided in the
description feel free also subscribe the
nerd medic channel where you can get
exclusive medical content
to like share and subscribe see you in
next video don't forget to
let us know in the comment how you like
our videos if you have a suggestion for